[موسيقى]
قبل اسابيع من مرور عام على بدء العمليه
الروسيه ضد اوكرانيا عادا للاذهان مشهد
جثه برصاصه في الجمجمه ملقات على رصيف وسط
العاصمه كياب
القتيل لم يكن مواطنا اوكرانيا عاديا
مقتله اثار جدلا واسعا فهل دينيس كريم
جاسوس روسي بطل تساؤلات لصحيفه
اجاب عليها مسؤولون حكوميون واستخبارات
انضم لمفاوضات السلام في ال 28 من فبراير
في بيلاروسيا في دور غير محدد الا ان
حضوره كان بطلب من الجانبين عده روايات
ومراسم دفن غير اعتياديه فمسول جهاز الامن
الاوكرانيه قال حينها ان دينيس كريف قتل
بصفته خائنا لتجسسه لصالح موسكو لكن بعد
ايام من القائل جثته كيرف الذي وصف
بالجاسوس وقتل على اساس ذلك دفن بطل بجوار
اول وزير خارجيه لاوكرانيا ووقع الرئيس
الاوكراني اوراقه لمنحه وساما لواجبه
الاستثنائي في الدفاع عن سياده الدوله
تقديرا لجهوده في الحيلوله دون تقدم
القوات الروسيه نحو العاصمه الاوكرانيه
فبراير العام الماضي بفضل معلومات بغايه
الدقه نقلها كريف من اتصالاته مع الروس
دورا الداهو الدينس كريم لم تنكره الجهات
الرسميه الا ان وفاته دفعت موسكو وكياف
للتحفظ على التعليق دفن مع مرتبه الشرف
العسكريه ومعه سره الا انه على مدى اشهر
ثلاث مقتله فتحت اوكرانيا اكثر من 650
قضيه خيانه تورط فيها مسؤولون حكوميون
روان حمزه العربيه